hey guys it's max after many years of
waiting apple finally updated their
airpods with the new airpods 3 and in
this video we not only are going to
compare them to the airpods 2 but also
the airpods pro to see
which one you should buy if you're
upgrading from the older model and what
kind of differences we get in terms of
sound quality microphone quality and
other differences now i'm also excited
to see the new magsafe charging case
with magnets in it and how that works
and as we get these out of the box you
guys see this the new updated design and
what really surprised me is that apple
actually
lowered the price we did not expect that
the airpods 2 with the wireless charging
case came in at 200 bucks these are now
180 putting them 70 dollars behind the
airpods pro
and look at that the air plus 3 case is
actually smaller than the airpods pro i
was expecting the same exact case but
that is not the case and if we look at
it compared to the airpods 2 case it's
basically the same size just that
different design where we have the top
that opens up compared to the side
making it taller the thickness is pretty
much the same but overall this means
that the airpods 3 is going to be more
comfortable in your pocket than the pros
now the next thing i want to test out is
that mag safe with these you can't
wirelessly charge but they're not going
to stick to it so you have to have a
flat charger but this one
bam look at that guys now this might
seem like a little thing but i do have a
maxi charger at my house a three and one
that we can't adjust the angle so i
can't just magnetically attach it like
this just adds a little bit of extra for
you so that is a cool feature and i
almost forgot my original airpods pro
don't have that mac save charging but if
you buy a brand new pair that's the
newest model they actually swap out the
case for the same max leaf magnets that
you get with the airpods 3. let's look
at the earbuds themselves it's
interesting that we have another vent at
the top here along with the one on the
outside and on the inside instead of
having it on the bottom with the air
pods pro or at least this is probably
optical sensor so that has changed but
other than that the shape and the design
looks very very similar of course we
don't have that silicon tip
that goes inside your ear but if we pop
that off it looks very similar compared
to the pro just slightly smaller the
stem design is the same but it is
actually thicker on the airpods 3 which
is why it might have the better battery
life both the butt itself and the case
so if you care about battery life
definitely go for the threes of course
compared to the airpods too the design
is a lot different but i want to say
that i love this design i love having
that pinch to control on that stem
instead of the tapping in your ear it's
a lot more accurate it's a lot simpler
to use it's definitely a good update and
since i already put them in my ear let's
talk about comfort now these air pods 3
definitely feel a little bit more snug
than the air pods 2.
i think the actual uh bud itself the
part goes into here it's a little bit
larger because that feels a little more
secure with the airpods too i can easily
move around and sometimes the stem will
touch my face
the threes yeah a little more snug but i
don't really feel any pressure and
that's why a lot of people actually like
these air pods because the pros they
have that seal that goes into your ear
okay yeah well this is very interesting
wow
so not only do i have that seal that
goes into my ear and they do have that
valve that releases pressure it almost
feels like the little bulb of the air
pod is actually a little bit larger on
the pro
then on the airpods 3 interesting so
with that said if you're somebody has
really small ears the air pots too might
still be more comfortable for you than
the threes which are larger i'm not
feeling pressure but i can sense that
it's larger or if the airpods 2 or the
originals fall out of your ears the
airpods 3 will do better but the airpods
pros even though they're comfortable for
in-ear design they are the least
comfortable now speaking of that sealed
design
that is what allows the air pods pro to
have noise cancellation and this could
be a game changer if you want to cut out
the outside world so right now they just
kicked in and our ac vet noise right
there
it literally went down to like maybe 20
of what it was before so if you're in
loud environments you travel you're on
buses trains whatever airplanes that is
so nice to have and then if you want to
hear your surroundings just like with
airpods two and three you just press
down switch it over to the transparency
mode and right now i'm hearing
everything just like i was wearing
oh yes i absolutely hear you with you
so with that if you care about that
we'll leave links down in the
description below to amazon where
there's often sales really good sales
for the airpods pro but even actually
picked up a pair the same price as the
new airpods 3 which is a killer deal
let's go ahead and test out the
microphones first this is the microphone
quality with apple's airpods too in a
normal room with hvac noise and this is
the microphone quality with apple's new
airpods 3 in a regular room that has
some hvac noise and this is the
microphone quality with apple's air pods
pro in a normal room with some hvac
noise and now let's get into sound
quality i'm excited to hear if these
sound better than airpods too and
especially the airpods pro that would be
crazy but first i want to mention that
with the airpods 3 and the pros unlike
the airpods 2 you get support for dolby
atmos that means if you're listening to
a track that has surround sound or has
positional audio it will allow you to
hear that and it sounds incredible same
thing for movies if you listen to atmos
you'll hear full surround sound and then
with that you can actually listen to
regular tracks and then go in and enable
something called spatialized stereo or
specialized audio so you can do head
tracking or you can select fixed now
what i noticed that with a lot of songs
especially those with guitars you get a
much better sound stage with this
virtualization
so you can actually hear the guitar
separated from the vocals and other
instruments and it is really a nice
effect for most songs now let's go ahead
and switch over where you are gonna
listen to three different tracks and
compare the sound
[Music]
[Music]
all right guys that was very
interesting something i didn't really
expect so the airpods too
these are louder for sure and i actually
checked on the little hearing app they
hit a hundred decibels
they're loud and they have to be loud
and the highs are very sharp very sharp
but also good bass surprisingly i
haven't listened to these for a while
they still sound good
now
with us switch the airpods pro i listen
these last they definitely sound better
than the airpods too in every single way
still good highs
great bass mids um they're not as loud
though they're definitely a little bit
quieter but they're sealed so you don't
need them to be um these sound great now
the brand new airpods 3 how do those
sound well believe it or not they
actually have better bass than the
sealed airpods pro
apple said there's a new driver design
it is really good whatever and i guess
on the base you really hear it sounds
good doesn't sound boomy sounds
controlled and the bass is definitely
there mids sound better than airplus 2
definitely just like the airpods pro
almost identical but the high
frequencies the vocals were a little bit
toned down um and i kind of like that i
like sharp highs
i guess i want to make sure i'm clear i
like the airpod pro's highs i'll have a
little bit more sharpness these are
basically right in between um these two
earbuds now i think either way you'll be
happy but overall i would have to give
the sound quality to the airpods pro now
this next song is this modern piano
instrumental with a beat drop and a lot
of tones this is really good for sound
stage so let's go ahead and take a
listen
[Music]
all righty wow okay
much bigger difference than before
each one of these sounds more different
that's why i like having multiple songs
to test first off
if you own one of these pairs airpods 2
or the original and you don't want to
spend the money don't try these out they
sound so much better in this song the
highs in these were so sharp and crisp
and crunchy sounding in some of the high
notes there and especially towards the
end where we have that huge mix of
instruments it just sounded like it was
distorting
that this song in that part makes a lot
of headphones to store if you have up
all the way so definitely and then with
that just the bass going into the
airpods three
man
now it didn't just sound like it was
maybe louder it digs deeper than even
the airpods pro that was clear better
than both of them
with that i didn't really feel like i
was missing any highs for this song all
the highs sounded really nice not overly
sharp very distinct and then the little
noise in the beginning of the song i can
hear it which it's there on purpose they
put it in there more so than the other
ones now as far as the overall sound
quality
this is tough this one was way closer
with the pros and the airpods three
maybe if you're not in a loud room i
would actually prefer the airpods three
because of the deeper bass and the highs
just sounded really nice as well
so i was surprised i did not expect that
now let's go ahead and do the last song
this is the toughest one this is a rock
track and with a lot of different
instruments and vocals
[Music]
is
[Music]
all right all right well
once again that was a good test
the airpods too they were distorting
it was very loud but didn't sound great
crunchy kind of sounding and then in the
middle of that sample there's a time
where you have all these instruments and
the vocals and that little synthesizer
um the little beat it literally got lost
in the mix everything was just jumbled
together
with the airpods 3 they got a lot
quieter than the airpods 2 and that's
probably because it has that inside
facing microphone that's constantly
eq'ing the song for it to sound its best
and it doesn't want it to distort so i
heard no distortion at all and the
instrument separation was way better i
still heard the synthetizer in the
background there uh vocal sounded good i
was really surprised switching over to
airpods pro
this is probably where they did their
worst now they also have that microphone
that faces in limits distortion they
were actually louder than the airpods 3
the vocals were a little bit brighter
but the bass was lacking the most
actually in this test and it makes sense
this is a very very hard song with all
those instruments they definitely sound
a lot better than the airpods 2 but not
as good as the airpods 3 it's apple's
newest driver design so that kind of
makes sense and they really stood out in
this test now with that said overall i
think you'll win either way with sound
quality if you listen to a lot of rock
probably go for these if you don't need
the seal design or the active noise
cancellation
for other songs simpler stuff the both
of these sound good but what you have to
know is what vadim was commenting he was
mentioning
how loud they were
sound leakage so airpods pro barely leak
any sound i mean you can still hear the
sound in the first track he still heard
it but he couldn't make out the words
but they're sealed and it's a lot better
airpods 3 they still leak sound almost
as much as the air pods too they
probably just leave leak less maybe
slightly slightly less just because the
highs aren't that bright and a little
bit quieter so if you care about other
people hearing your music you don't want
one of these if you like to turn them up
you want the pros and then of course
that noise cancellation also helps if
you're in loud environments like public
places as well so there you guys go we
have the new airpods three against
airpods pro
or the original airpods so
verdict final verdict
don't buy the airpods too unless you're
buying it for a kid or somebody like
that's more of the convenience of having
apple's product where it can sync across
different
apple devices that's what they're good
for now if you're upgrading from airpods
to or earpods one to one of these
what's a much tougher choice you can buy
these on sale we have a link down below
they have active noise cancellation some
of the extra features um and they don't
leak sound airpods 3 they do sound
better they do have that magsafe
connection which is pretty cool and the
battery life is better so it's a newer
design smaller case that's more
comfortable
and all of that does matter so if you
don't need active noise cancellation you
don't care about sound leakage i would
go for air pods three if you do care
about those things go for the air pods
pro
and you guys let me know your thoughts
down below which one you guys went for
so you guys can click that circle above
to subscribe check out one of the other
great videos right over there this one
max and i will see you in the next video
[Music]